Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is a caller who is
bravely engaged in fighting the war on Christmas,
which doesn't exist. Okay. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: David, sir, this is James.
We had a good Hanukkah. Thank you.
I wanted to talk to you about the issue of the war
on Christmas. Yes. With maybe one exception, I've
never actually heard of anyone get offended when
someone says Merry Christmas, but I can't tell
you how many right wingers I've heard get offended
by happy holidays. I think it's time that that the
progressives really, really call the Republicans
out on their on their wokeness and their.
Speaker 1: Their police speech. Someone
says Happy holidays and they go,
Why aren't you saying Merry Christmas to me?
Speaker 2: Happy holidays. They really are
snowflakes. Happy holidays triggers in
that much. Yeah. Hardly anyone actually
gets offended by Merry Christmas. Anyway, I hope
you have a good rest of your holiday season and.
Hope to hear from you soon.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, listen,
I tweeted the other day and some people got so
mad at me, I was serious when I tweeted it. But
it's not like some big thing when people say
happy holidays to me around this time of year,
I go, Oh, happy holidays. Yeah. And if
they say Merry Christmas, I say, Oh,
happy Hanukkah. It's just like, it's not a big
deal. I'm not doing it aggressively. It's just
if they wish me Merry Christmas, because that's
what they celebrate. I wish them Happy Hanukkah
because that's what I celebrate. It's not a big
deal. No one has ever gotten upset. No one has
ever gotten offended. It's kind of a joke.
But I do do that. Do that. I'm not offended.
Nobody's offended. It's really not a big deal.
The thing that really does seem to offend people
is these right wingers, when they are told
happy holidays, they believe they are being
told to happy holidays because some woke Marxist
leftist Obama. Yeah. Like Obama or whoever it.
Has pressured a worker at Best Buy to forgo Merry
Christmas and instead to say Happy Holidays. So
it is true. I don't. Wish me happy Kwanzaa. I
don't care. Wish me whatever you want. And then
I'll respond however I want. No one's offended.
We're having conversations. It's fine. Okay. But
the people who get offended are the ones wished
happy holidays when they believe they should be
wished. Merry Christmas and it's pathetic.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
This it's unbelievable that this even happened.
At least 27 people are dead in Buffalo, New York,
because of a snowstorm. Okay. We're going to
talk about the horrifying situation in Buffalo,
Adidas. Much less seriously. Adidas is scrambling
to sell over $500 million worth of Yeezys after
cutting ties with Kanye West. What are they going
to do with them? Where are they going to end up?
It's an interesting place, by the way, where
sometimes clothing and shoes end up when they
are no longer sold on the retail market. We'll
talk about that. And a new poll finds that Arizona
now independent Senator Kirsten Cinema would get
crushed if she ran as an independent in 2024,
which was supposedly one of the considerations
in her moving from Democrat to Independent.
All of those stories and so much more all
on today's bonus show. How do you get the
bonus show you sign up at join Packman dot com.
Speaker 3: O the bonus show where you want to make
money. Yes. Everybody else that makes money to.
Speaker 2: Fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, depends how you're making that
money, Alex. That's the truth. We're offering
nothing other than a good time with the award
winning bonus show. You can sign up at join
Packman dot com. You can use the coupon code.
Please no more Trump. And you have to say it
that way when you enter it. Please no more Trump.
We'll see you on the bonus show in mere moments.